vielleicht hinter der angekündigten zeit
aber dafür im sinne einer gründlichen
recherche unserer informationen die wir
ihnen jetzt mitteilen möchten
darf ich sie hier begrüßen bei uns auf
dem podium zu meiner rechten der
münchner polizeipräsident hubertus andrä
unternehmen der präsident des
bayerischen landeskriminalamt robert
heimberger auch nicht nach zudem
begrüßen
von der staatsanwaltschaft münchen 1
herrn thomas steinkraus koch
komm mit recht zum eingemachten der
aktuelle sachstand vom einer seite das
einen guten morgen im grüß gott ich
möchte mit ganz wesentlichen kern
informationen beginnen
zum ersten es gibt keinerlei hinweise
auf grund der intensiven ermittlungen
dass mehr als der selbst sich selbst
getötet die täter hier aktiv waren
sodass es also auch aus unserer sicht
jetzt eindeutig ist dass es hier mit
einem einzeltäter zu tun haben
zweite kern botschaft die mir auch ganz
wichtig ist tat und täter haben nach dem
derzeitigen stand überhaupt keinen bezug
zum thema flüchtlinge dritter
kernaussage ist dass es aus
sicherheitsgründen überhaupt keine
veranlassung gibt münchen nicht zu
besuchen in münden nicht einzukaufen
oder veranstaltungen abzusagen so weit
ist zu veranstaltungs absagen kommt weil
der veranstalter aus pietätsgründen
nicht möchte ist es was anderes aber
sicherheitsgründen gibt es keine
rechtfertigung für eine absage unser
täter ist 18 jahre alt ist in münchen
geboren aufgewachsen und ist schüler
seine wohnzimmer seine wohnung bzw sein
zimmer in dem er gelebt hat wurde
zwischenzeitlich durchsucht es gibt
aufgrund untersuchung keinerlei
anhaltspunkte für einen bezug zum s
vielmehr wurden unterlagen gefunden aus
dem bereich amok mit dem thema hat sich
der täter offensichtlich intensiv
beschäftigt so den quoten ist zu sagen
dass wir insgesamt zehn tote haben
konnte derzeit 27 verletzte personen
davon sind zehn personen schwer verletzt
unter den schwer verletzten befindet
sich auch ein 13-jähriger 17 personen
sind leicht verletzt von den 27
verletzten haben vier personen
schussverletzungen
die zahl 27 bei den verletzten
resultiert auch daraus dass aus den
anderen ereignissen worten wie stachus
oder hofbräuhaus und ähnliche dinge dort
auch personen verletzt worden die jetzt
auch in dieser zahl beinhaltet sind
natürlich können sich diese zahlen was
die verletzten angeht
entsprechend hier im laufe des tages
noch verändern weil ja nicht
auszuschließen ist dass der eine oder
die andere dann selber sich in ärztliche
behandlung begeben hat zum tatort ist zu
sagen dass der tatort in teilbereichen
aufgrund der nächtlichen arbeit unserer
kollegen und kolleginnen wieder
freigegeben werden konnte der nahbereich
und der engeren bereich insbesondere um
das schnellrestaurant bleiben weiterhin
abgesperrt
ob und wann gegebenenfalls wieder das iz
den einkaufs betrieb eröffnen kann kann
man derzeit noch nicht abschätzen
der öffentliche personennahverkehr läuft
wieder planmäßig mit ausnahme dass eben
hier bestimmte station nicht angefahren
wird aber ansonsten läuft der verkehr
wieder planmäßig für uns jetzt sozusagen
das weitere prozedere dass der tatort
weiter entsprechend bearbeitet werden
muss
die ermittlungen beziehen
sicher da passieren natürlich in erster
linie auf vernehmungen auch aus dem
persönlichen umfeld und darf das auch
sehr deutlich sagen das muss natürlich
jetzt auch mit der entsprechenden
sensibilität gemacht werden weil
natürlich die auch für die angehörigen
des ein schwerer schicksalsschlag ist
ansonsten laufen jetzt die ermittlungen
wie gesagt weiter wir hatten ja zur
spitzenzeit circa 2.300 einsatzkräfte im
bereich minden unterwegs
zurzeit sind wir mit etwa 800
einsatzkräfte noch im dienst da es sind
auch die kriminalbeamten entsprechend
mit aufgenommen wir heute nacht
berichtet dass eine zivilstreife von uns
kontakt zum täter hatte das hat sich
jetzt entsprechend bestätigt der kontakt
fand im bereich der hauses vom oez statt
dort wurde der täter von den kollegen
gesichtet und ein kollege hat dann auf
den täter auch geschossen aus dem
obduktionsergebnis kann man feststellen
dass es keinen treffer durch die polizei
gegeben hat das ist sozusagen der
aktuelle und upgedatet sachstand zum
verfahren derzeit der hainberger und der
steinkraus-koch werden dann noch baut
details zum ermittlungsverfahren sollen
das thema was ist eine gute überleitung
heimwerker bitte auch von mir herzlichen
grüß gott
wir haben ja in der vergangenen nacht an
die ermittlungen übernommen und sind
hier intensiv momentan dabei die
hintergründe und die näheren
tatumständen wir abzuklären was sie
interessieren dürfte der feder hatte
eine glock dabei eine neun millimeter
waffe wohl illegal weil die nummer
ausgefeilt ist die müssen wir jetzt erst
durch technische maßnahmen wieder
sichtbar machen um dann feststellen zu
können woher die waffe stammt
es wird noch eine zeit lang dauern im
magazin befand sich noch entsprechende
munition und im rucksack den er mit
geführt hat hat er als auch eine größere
anzahl von patronen von schuss
mitgeführt über 300 schuss hat der täter
mit dabei gehabt
der zweite schwerpunkt war die
durchsuchung der wohnungen eltern und
seines zimmers wie schon eher andré
angedeutet hat wurden hier keine es
bezüge gefunden sondern vielmehr
zeitungsartikel die sich mit
polizeieinsätzen wie sich mit amoklagen
befasst haben unter anderem auch ein
buch mit dem titel amok im kopf warum
schüler töten also scheinbar dass sich
hier entsprechend mit amok laden und
sonstigen vergleichbaren sachverhalten
befasst
des weiteren eine umfangreiche tv
material sichergestellt
auch das ist momentan in der auswertung
sie wissen dass wir große daten umfänge
gibt das wird jetzt in aller akribie und
und feinheit ausgewertet und erst am
firma tafel recht weiteres sagen dass
soweit zu den ermittlungskomplexen wie
wir momentan schwerpunktmäßig bearbeiten
narrhalla finanzen dank dann vielleicht
aus dem bereich justiz rechtliche
bewertung herrn steinkraus koch
grüß gott auch von mir erstmal die
staatsanwaltschaft mainz führt seit
gestern abend ein ermittlungsverfahren
wegen mordes
wir gehen hier zwar zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt davon aus dass es nur einen
täter der auch getötet wurde
beziehungsweise der sich selbst
gerichtet hat gibt nichtsdestotrotz wenn
man das ermittlungsverfahren
weiterführen auch auf die frage hin gibt
es hier irgend jemand der mit diesen
waffen in verbindung steht mit der
munition in verbindung steht
das würde uns schon noch sehr gerne
interessieren wir stehen im ständigen
austausch und kontakt mit der
generalbundesanwaltschaft schon seit
gestern nachdem aber aufgrund der funde
insbesondere in der wohnung mit diesem
material über ein amoklauf gehen wir
davon aus dass es sich um einen
klassischen amoktäter ohne jegliche
politische motivation handelt deshalb
erscheint die zuständigkeit des
generalbundesanwalts derzeit nicht
eröffnet er hat deshalb eine übernahme
derzeit abgelehnt wir werden aber weiter
in kontakt stehen sind aber der
auffassung das verfahren wird bei uns
bleiben
zum täter kann ich ihnen aus der
obduktion die an seiner leiche gerade
abgeschlossen worden ist mitteilen
es befindet sich nur eine
schussverletzung es ist ein aufgesetzter
schuss im kopfbereich
mit der verbindung dass er linkshänder
ist und dass der schuss kann als sich
hier in verbindung bringen lässt gehen
wir davon aus es ist ein suizid er hat
sich selbst berichtet anhaltspunkte
hierfür dass er von einem polizei
projektil getroffen worden
es gibt es derzeit nicht neueste
informationen es ihn selber kann man
natürlich nicht mehr näher befragen ist
dass er sich in ärztlicher und sogar in
psychiatrischer behandlung befunden
haben soll das bitte noch mit vorbehalt
es soll sich hier um eine erkrankung aus
dem depressiven formenkreis gehandelt
haben das würde war nach unserem ersten
einschätzung ins gesamtbild passen
bislang ist er bei uns nicht als
beschuldigter in den dateien in
erscheinung getreten
nur einmal als geschädigter in zwei
verfahren einem jahr 2012 und einmal im
jahr 2010 das eine war eine körperliche
auseinandersetzung mit drei anderen
jugendlichen des wurde wegen
geringfügigkeit eingestellt und das
andere war geschädigte eines diebstahls
da haben wir keinen täter ermittelt aber
wir erkennen ihn sonst nicht weder in
strafrechtlicher noch insbesondere in
staatsschutz rechtlicher hinsicht ist
bei uns akten mäßig bekannt so weit von
mir
der einkaufskorb vielen herzlichen dank
da sie wahrscheinlich trotz diesem sehr
dichten der vortrag der sachlage nach
wie vor fragen haben werden möchte ich
dem mann andré noch raum geben
der hat nämlich ein fazit für sie
zunächst möchte ich mich ganz herzlich
bedanken nach bei der bevölkerung die
großes verständnis für die polizeiliche
situation für die polizeiliche arbeit
uns entgegengebracht hat um das auch zum
beispiel wir die sozialen medien
entsprechend uns gut getan hat dafür ein
ganz herzliches dankeschön ein ganz
großes dankeschön geht auch an alle
einsatzkräfte egal ob sie vom leben von
den anderen verbänden von den
unterstützungskräften hat den anderen
bundesländern an die gsg9 oder an die
kobra aus österreich die unterstützung
und die zusammenarbeit haben
hervorragend funktioniert und ich würde
ja heute nacht gefragt wie viele notrufe
in zusammenhang mit diesem ereignis bei
uns eingingen
und das haben wir natürlich
zwischenzeitlich recherchiert vom
zeitpunkt der tat bis 24 uhr gingen 4310
notrufe bei uns ein
damit sie sich einmal ein volumen
vorstellen könnte es ist der wert von 4
tagen eigentlich bei normalen betriebs
so zu sagen wir haben pro tag etwa 1000
bis 1100 notruf einsätze und jetzt
hatten wir in der zeit von 18 bis 24 uhr
quasi das vierfache können sie erkennen
welche belastung da entsprechend auf der
einsatzzentrale gelegen hat und
natürlich auch gegen konsequenz dass es
viele anrufe gab die dann letztendlich
nicht durchkommen oder nicht zeitnah
abgearbeitet werden kann aber es liegt
rein und dieser enormen zahl innerhalb
von sechs stunden sozusagen die
vierfache eines tages wird es soweit auf
einer seite noch zu ergänzen
das jetzt erstmal unser teil
sie sind gefragt im wahrsten sinne des
wortes der erster hand ist oben
bitteschön facebook postings gab die
daten komplett vom rezept gegen ein aus
ich gebe eine ausübung so ganz gut
es gibt wohl erste erkenntnisse die
allerdings noch abgeklärt werden müssen
dass der täter einen facebook account
gehackt hat und in diesen gehackten
facebook-account zum zu diesem
schnellrestaurant am osz eingeladen hat
er würde dort spendieren was sie wollen
aber nicht so teuer das war wohl die
einladung
das müssen wir erst noch tatsächlich
verifizieren aber es spricht vieles
dafür dass das von dem täter
eingerichtet wurde und dann entsprechend
auch verschickt wurde oder oder zur
verfügung gestellt wurde
das ist spekulation da kann ich nichts
dazu sagen muss ich tatsächlich spontan
gerne in der mitte
kind
gestorben
mehr
prof
und gleich
toten den kollegen sagen das ist zu den
toten personen kann ihnen sagen dass es
sich alles um personen handelt die aus
münchen und umgebung stammen also keine
auswärtige oder touristen betroffen sind
die toten sind 15 jahre alt und zwar
zwei mal drei mal 14 jahre alt einmal 17
jahre alt
einmal 19 jahre alt einmal 20 jahre alt
und 1 x 45 jahre alt und unter täter 18
jahre unter den toten sind drei frauen
alles andere muss jetzt über die
identitäts klärung abgeklärt werden
welche nationalitäten und aber das ist
sozusagen bei dem toten davon lässt sich
daraus schließen
doch zeigen auch schon bestätigen dass
der täter gezielt jugendliche sitzen
leute ungefähr ins visier genommen hat
das komme weder bestätigen noch
dementieren
das wird in erster linie ermittlungs
sache sein die wir hand von
zeugenaussagen und vor allem auch dann
von dem videomaterial des uns ja
teilweise schon zur verfügung steht und
auch zur verfügung gestellt wird dann
eben nachvollziehbar prüfen muss auf
jeden hatte gezielt geschossen hat
überhaupt gezielt geschossen wie sie
vorgegangen
da sind wir natürlich aus meiner sicht
nur am anfang der herren fuß der stadt
freie betten
wenn sie besteht viele wohnungen gäste
durchs land fahren
jetzt haben wir nur eine wohnung
durchsucht und zwar die die ihm
sozusagen selbst gehört wo er selbst
gewohnt hat die dame tschuldigung mit
also abschiedsbrief an bisher noch nicht
gefunden wie gesagt die elephant
ausgewertet werden das schließe ich
jetzt nicht aus aber bisher haben wir
nichts gefunden
es hat auch jetzt konkret nichts ist
nichts gefunden was auf diese konkrete
tat gedeutet hätte mit ausnahme dessen
was ich vorher gesagt hat und bitte um
verständnis bei den eltern
die waren nicht mehr vernehmungsfähig
initiative in der wir das brauchen denn
sie an schließlich auch ihren sohn
verloren und das sind nach ermittlungen
die jetzt zug um zug einfach
durchgeführt werden besteht ihre frage
der schrecken herausgestellt was es geht
und was bekommt
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir danach
passieren oder die folge davon ist ja
diese hohe anzahl von notrufen dass wir
immer wieder hinweise aus dem ganzen
stadtgebiet bekommen hat dass da
irgendwo geschossen wurde
das war ja auch der grund warum wir dann
letztendlich uns entschieden haben den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr
sozusagen fast einzustellen
die kubaner komplett und die busse und
die s bahn gingen bis ostbahnhof bis
pasing solche informationen solche
hinweise
die sind natürlich für uns mehr arbeit
wir müssen natürlich und gehen auch
diesen hinweisen sofort mit
entsprechenden kräften nach mit
entsprechenden ermittlungen und gott sei
dank hat sich ja keiner dieser hinweise
damals real lesen
das habe ich ein teil ein automatisches
wegschicken und weiterverteilt ist da
nicht hilfreich das sollte man wirklich
auf die informationen der polizei
vertrauen und sich an diesen
informationen orientieren
also fotos von einem pflege es ist
manchmal schwierig zu sagen fällt weil
man ja nicht genau auf anhieb erkennen
kann warum es zu dieser situation kommt
da wird natürlich wenn die leute
hochsensibel sind vielleicht eine
verhaltensweise als plötzliche bedrohung
erkannt dann beginnt jemand zu schreien
und dann setze ich das wieder in die
welle folgt das möchte ich gar nicht als
fake oder als fehlmeldung darstellen das
ist ja tatsächlich auch passiert wir
haben ja auch verletzte personen also
das ist ja nicht irgendwie keine scherze
meldung gewesen
es war eine unbestätigte meldung
zunächst und die hat uns natürlich
machen uns die arbeit aber ich glaube
das muss nicht verhindern kann in
bestimmten situationen aber das teilen
ohne dass ich dazu sozusagen tatsächlich
was bestätigung ab oder dass ich etwas
weiß
das macht uns natürlich zum zusätzliche
arbeit das ist nämlich die frage gleich
dahingehend ergänzen bevölkerung ängste
nehmen wir wahr und wir kennen das auch
als motiv an
aber wir recherchieren natürlich diese
bilder sehr intensiv vor allem auch die
kollegen vom regal die das update portal
betreuen sollten wir dort hinweise haben
dass jemand gezielt desinformation
streut und einen entsprechenden nachweis
auch führen können wird das erhebliche
rechtliche konsequenzen für die personen
nahmen die frau dube
dass es auch einfach logistische gründe
hat
zuerst gibt der polizei gefunden hat
also zunächst einmal es heute im
stadtgebiet mehrere möglichkeiten geben
das stadthaus marienplatz hofbräuhaus
mathäser häuser zahlreiche örtlichkeit
gegeben die also hier sozusagen dann
angeblich betroffen waren
wenn sie eine erste meldung bekommen
dass jemand schießt und dass es
verletzte oder gar tote gegeben hat dann
müssen wir und gehen wir von der
höchsten einsatz situation in der
höchsten gefährdungsstufe aus solange
wir nicht entsprechende erkenntnisse
haben dass sich die gefährdungssituation
verändert hat runter gefahren hat und
auch erledigt hat alles andere wäre
völlig unprofessionell zu sagen jetzt
erst einmal bis mehr erkenntnisse haben
die zeit die wir dann verlieren würden
die können wir nicht mehr aufholen und
deshalb ist es absolut richtig und
notwendig gewesen
in dieser hohen stufe sozusagen
einzusteigen
also wir haben die information
getwittert und das war die derzeitige
oder die aktuelle einschätzung die
zunächst einmal vorhanden war und ich
glaube da brauchen wir uns auch nichts
drüber glaube ich groß diskutieren und
gedanken machen wenn sie so was twittern
dann wird automatisch auch im grunde
genommen von jedermann die vermutung
geäußert dass es sich um eine terror
gehandelt wir haben aufgrund dieser
information eben die höchste einsatz
stufe ausgelöst die wir zur verfügung
darüber war man bisher noch überhaupt
keine erkenntnisse
wie gesagt ein schüler aber auch das
umfeld wird jetzt erst aufgeklärt und
und ermittelt wie er keine fragen
einwürfe und bitte keine ketten fragen
das ist ein akt der kollegialität ich
lasse keine ketten fragen zur bernstein
hat sich die ganze zeit auf der wand
dann braucht immer auf dem parkdeck weiß
man über unter drogen- medikamenten-
halten
es ist derzeit steht es noch nicht fest
es wird auch die toxikologische
untersuchung einige zeit in anspruch
nehmen erfahrungsgemäß von der
reihenfolge reha mit der brille und dem
grünen tisch hat was bei einer schule
hat er denn gesucht
wir wollen zur schule und die schule ist
derzeit keine auskunft erteilt
wir wollen zur schule war schüler und
wir wollen zur schule ist aber keine
auskunft der herum feuermelder
andere mädchen durch
die beschaffung zu
die gedanken aus
vereinigen hintergrund gehen
nochmal es handelt sich um eine pistole
der marke glock 17
und wo sie herkommt und sonstiges muss
erst müssen erst die ermittlungen
ergeben wenn man dann einmal wissen
welche seriennummer wird und wo sie dann
her kommt jedenfalls kaum ergänzt eine
waffenrechtliche erlaubnis hatte er
jedenfalls nicht in der reihenfolge der
herr mit dem weißen hemd im anschluss
die anderen notausgang gefunden worden
sie war bisher überhaupt keine
erkenntnisse dass auf seinem pc spiel
wurde deutlich mit ballerspielen
beschäftigt haben und den attentäter von
winnenden damals in amokläufer
verherrlicht haben können sie das
bestätigen und inwiefern ausgeführt dass
weiter zur sicherung entsprechendes
material gefunden würde die sich mit dem
thema beschäftigt und das ihm auch
umfangreiche sozusagen sichergestellt
wurde
da läuft die auswertung so passen also
uns jetzt momentan was auf den anlagen
wird anlagen genau darauf ist uns
momentan noch keine erkenntnisse
vorliegen
auszuschließen ist es natürlich nicht
wenn ich mich sehr intensiv mit dem
thema beschäftigen das war die meldung
und dann der herr von der kamera
das müssen wir jetzt bis auf das was wir
wissen
zu dieser möglichen psychiatrischen
erkrankung ansonsten in ruhe abklären
sie müssen sich vorstellen das umfeld
muss jetzt abgeklärt werden
freunde bekannte befragt aber das ist
jetzt alles nicht in der nacht möglich
und da bitte ich auch um etwas
verständnis und geduld informieren
wollten sie bereits ihre toten kinder
also ich gehe davon aus dass die
informiert sind und aber in engen
zeitlichen korridor wir gerade uns
bewegen habe da schon alle entsprechend
ihre kinder sehen konnten gereichen
sehen kommt es kontinents eine
reihenfolge der kameramann auf dem tisch
und anschließend besuchen sie die
gleiche schule oder kunden in beiden
quartieren auch das ist natürlich jetzt
alle ermittlungen und soweit die opfer
vernehmungsfähig sind wird es
schnellstmöglich gemacht und an
ansonsten ist natürlich auch diese frage
eine frage die wir im umfeld des täters
sozusagen mit den ermittlungen abklären
müssen aber ich wie gesagt bitten um
verständnis wir sind jetzt wenige
stunden nach dem vorfall
da können wir einfach noch nicht alle
ermittlungen haben und
ermittlungsergebnisse haben und in der
ersten phase ging es uns darum dass wir
möglichst halle gefahren und möglichst
gefahren für die bevölkerung hier
abwehren und erst nachdem klar war dass
der tatort auch für unsere kollegen
sicher zu begehen ist kommen dann
letztendlich die entsprechenden
ermittlungen aufgenommen und
intensiviert werden
gestern nacht relativ grob den part auch
ablaufen müssen zum beispiel die frage
ob man im auto zum tatort gefahren ist
wurde nicht beantwortet man meist immer
wusste nicht genau was genau liebsten
schnelles tor ab wo genau bei welchen
geschäften die lange wie du dich auf und
wurde dann auch seine leiche gefunden
kann man viel stand jetzt im zeitablauf
vielleicht ein bisschen selber
beschreiben also wie häufig und auch das
muss ich sie einfach um geduld bitten
und um verständnis bitten das ist sache
der ermittlungen
wir haben heute versucht mit einem
mantrailer uns einen weg
nachzuvollziehen
und das immerhin gerade dabei das ganze
entsprechend aufzuklären und und mehr
abzuklären
hätte ich eine gelbe karte würde ich sie
jetzt hochhalten
das war eine wortmeldung hier und da er
mit der brille
es gibt einen bruder über den lägen auch
keine erkenntnisse vor
zu details der erkrankungen liegen uns
noch keine näheren informationen vor
dass es jetzt ein erster zuruf den wir
erhalten haben der wie gesagt ins bild
passen würde zudem verhalten dass uns
beschrieben wurde ist aber das muss
alles in ruhe aufgeklärt werden
das kann
eine frage haben sie erkenntnisse
darüber dass er sich auch mit diesem
attentat von luxburg 17 jährigen
afghanen beschäftigt hat zum einen das
thema langwaffe ist nicht aktuell
das war mal eine information aber es hat
sich überhaupt nie bestätigt dass er
langlauf im einsatz war und er sich
irgendwann irgendwie mit würzburg
beschäftigt dort wissen wir nicht
objektive informationen über objektive
anhaltspunkte dafür gibt es nicht auch
noch mal die informationen die uns
momentan vorliegen ist die beschäftigung
des täters mehr auf dem bereich amok und
nicht überhaupt keine erkenntnisse im
bereich es weil er hier vorne und dann
als nummer zwei der herr mit dem blauen
t-shirt
ich habe eine frage studiert
man sieht sein
haben sie
in den fokus
wenn er aus der wohnung raus gekommen
sind
also all diese vernehmungen müssen jetzt
erst er durchgeführt werden und so wie
es der kollege heimberger gesagt hat
aufgrund der situation sind die
unmittelbaren angehörigen nicht derzeit
nicht oder heute nacht nicht
vernehmungsfähig
und insofern kann man diese fragen der
zeit auch nicht beantworten
sie sind einfach daran teil der
befragung aber wie gesagt das rede ja
auch darum dass die eltern wissen was
ihr sohn sozusagen angestellt hat dass
er schuld ist für viele tote und dass er
selbst dass sie selbst ein kind verloren
haben und da glaube ich es auch
nachvollziehbar dass man in der
situation dann eben nicht
vernehmungsfähig
könnten sie vielleicht sagen zum einsatz
noch mal was sagen zum einsatz der gsg 9
war die angefordert worden
von welcher seite die sie zum einsatz
gekommen die ehe stand der dinge reden
die gsg 9 ist von uns angefordert wurden
so wie es unsere einsatzkonzeption
hervor sind gsg9 wurde dann im
entsprechend auch vom
bundesinnenministerium uns als
unterstützung zugesagt sie wurde luft ta
lasteten auf mitgebracht und wurde dann
auch zum einsatz gebracht einsätze die
hier erledigt wurden sind zum beispiel
das betreten der wohnung des
tatverdächtigen und auch war sie bereit
gestanden für eventuelle hinweise die
auf mögliche sonstige schießereien oder
ähnliche dinge auflaufen bei uns hier im
entsprechend schnell reagieren und
handeln zu können
denn ich habe ein nachbar verstanden
dass der schütze mit deinen eltern
zutritt zu der wohnung
oder der bruder auch
meine erste frage lang zweite frage ganz
ganz einfach die familie wohnt in einer
wohnung alle zusammen
personen sind unter polizeischutz
gestellt worden und weitere festnahmen
gab ist mit dem verlauf nicht
die welches über ausländer münzen haben
soll und beteuerte seine deutschland mit
also wir gehen momentan davon aus dass
dieses video den täter zeigt auf dem
dach wir mit einem anwohner der den film
auf entsprechend kommuniziert was genau
gesagt wurde und wann und wie und vom
leben muss jetzt auch ermittelt werden
und dann kommen auch diese fragen erst
denken dann gegebenfalls beantworten
frau joop und laden daher mit
vorhand-winner eben
so legen uns momentan keine erkenntnisse
vor dass könnten er uns nur die eltern
oder nahe angehörige oder freunde
bezugspersonen sagen da man derzeit
keine erkenntnisse
das ist ja für uns auch ein indiz
gestern war der fünfte jahrestag von
preisig und wenn sich jemand so intensiv
mit dem thema amok beschäftigt dann wird
natürlich auch der fall breinig mit
sicherheit eine rolle gespielt haben mit
der beschäftigung weil wenig mit dem
thema das intensiv beschäftigen dann ist
es ja fast auf der hand liegt
wir wissen
nein das ist zunächst nur mal das faktum
dass gestern der fünfte jahrestag war
und eben das faktum dass sich unser
täter sehr sehr intensiv mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat und wenn sie jemand so
intensiv mit dem thema beschäftigt dann
glaube ich muss man einfach davon
ausgehen
zunächst einmal annahme dass es sich
auch mit dem fall beschäftigt hat weil
das jahr der gravierendste amoklauf
überhaupt ist und daher diese verbindung
sozusagen liegt auf der hand
der herr der lamelle und im anschluss
der herr ganz links
aber ausländische opfer ausgesucht hat
oder ob die ausländischen aussehen
die nationalitäten das muss jetzt im
rahmen der ermittlungen genau geklärt
werden welche staatsangehörige unser ein
und sofort ob dass der täter gezielt
gemacht hat das ist aus meiner sicht
dann auch eine frage der rekonstruktion
des ablaufes wir versuchen anhand ja
dann bzw slk dann anhand insbesondere
auch der videoaufnahmen die jetzt
ausgewertet zusammengeführt werden
müssen
seitlich zusammen geführt werden müssen
welches video zeigt welchen
zeitabschnitt und erst dann kommen die
es im grunde genommen klären ob star
entsprechenden ansatz geht er ist daher
und dann komme ich gerne noch auf sie
zurück
ja wir haben etwa 100 personen bei uns
im präsidium aufgenommen in einem raum
die aufgrund einer entsprechenden
information angst hatten
und natürlich dann gesehen haben dass
jedes polizeipräsidium ist und sich ins
polizeipräsidium rhein gegeben haben die
wurden bei uns in einem raum
entsprechend betreut und als sich die
lage wieder beruhigt hat dann auch
wieder in die straße gelassen
darüber hinaus haben wir auch zahlreiche
hinweise darauf dass die aktion auch in
der breiten bevölkerung umgesetzt wurde
wie intensiv kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
aber wir haben belege dafür dass
personen ihre wohnung zur verfügung
gestellt haben eine reihenfolge der
lamelle und anschließend 300 man sagen
aufgrund der
der leitung ob der täter ein geübter
schütze war oder oder nicht wir können
noch nicht sagen wie oft der täter
geschossen hat das ist jetzt eben ein
mehr intensive spurensuche an den
tatorten und genausowenig können wir
sagen aber ein geübter schütze war das
wird wohl auch aus dem videoauswertungen
dann vielleicht noch zu erkennen sein
oder aus dem umfeld ermittlungen derzeit
kann man auch nicht an die eltern wenn
jemand in seinem umfeld gewusst haben
daher eine waffe tötet
doch jetzt keine hinweise derzeitige
ermittlungsstand versuchen erstmal
dreier paket der herr von reuters dann
anschließend der herren kann und dann
die damen beim fenster
mutig
spaß oder auf
der zweite teil
vergessen
nicht haben die nicht vom täter fest
die starttaste verbesserung
der verstand
also die getöteten personen wurden
sowohl im bereich des schnellrestaurants
innen im lokal als auch auf der straße
vor dem lokal aber auch entsprechend
getötete personen im bereich des
einkaufszentrums wird spannend gefunden
wie die genau zum beispiel lagen und
große genau sagen
zahlenmäßig und ist aus dem ärmel
darstellungen